le corps est entièrement ouvert
s
pesées disséquer et répertorié
[Musique]
quand vous prenez un peu de recul il y a
des fois vous dites mais c'est un moule
ignoble
c'est ignoble donc pour survivre à
l'ignoble il faut en faire un objet
sinon psychologiquement c'est pas
possible enfin ou alors c'est très
difficile ou alors on souffre
aujourd'hui dans une cour d'assise ce
que dit le médecin légiste est considéré
comme
s'en bavure sans discussion
[Musique]
ces familles
sont contents de voir la dernière
personne qui s'est occupée en fait
compte de la rue des fins de voir un peu
notre notre tête et c'est vraiment
important pour eux qu'on leur explique
de quoi est mort
surtout quand c'est un petit peu violent
c'est c'est important
[Musique]
l'avantage de faire de la médecine
légale l'avantage de voir des cadavres
Google journée de les découper d'étudier
leur cause de mort c'est que vous
comprenez la valeur de la vie
[Musique]
8h du matin quelque part dans la
campagne au poids de vigne
[Applaudissements]
Michel sapinest se rend sur son lieu de
travail
une scène de crime
bonjour je suis le médecin légiste
d'accord allez-y
mais une scène de crime un peu
particulière une reconstitution dans les
conditions du réel c'est Michel sapenet
qui a tout organisé il a placé à l'abri
des regards un vrai squelette et une
arme dans un sous-bois le but de cette
simulation est de former les gendarmes
de l'identification criminelle et une
étudiante en médecine en 20 ans de
métiers Michel sapanay a travaillé sur
des centaines de scènes de crimes
passionnés par son métier il en a écrit
un livre à chaque fois il suit les mêmes
règles ne pas se précipiter s'imprégner
des lieux moi j'ai une organisation en
trois cercles que j'ai massé j'arrive
près de ma forêt c'est mon premier
cercle quel type de forêt qu'est-ce que
je peux y trouver comme animaux est-ce
qu'il y a des sangliers qui sont
susceptibles d'être passé par là bonjour
quel type de terrain est-ce que j'ai
c'est des feuillus c'est des conifères
est-ce que la terre est acide est-ce
qu'elle est calcaire voilà ça c'est mon
premier cercle et puis là dedans je
rajoute la météo de ces derniers jours
arrivés sur les lieux de son assistante
et surtout de Lolita sa stagiaire en
dernier année de médecine
l'objectif de la journée lui apprendre à
travailler sur une scène de crime et lui
donner l'envie de devenir légiste elle a
encore tout à apprendre le directeur
d'enquête nous a prévenu il y a une
heure à peu près de ça comme quoi il y
avait un fronter qui a découvert un
squelette là où il y a les fléchages
et les numéros et puis
on n'a pas fouillé encore welcran nu
elle est encore habillée on a retrouvé
des chaussures et là on a trouvé une
arme là on essaie de dégager un peu donc
on pense qu'il y a eu des erreur une
bagarre ou une un truc comme ça enfin
c'est pas naturel quoi
vous voyez le médecin légiste un peu
star cravate sur le scène de crime il
vaut mieux éviter les gendarmes de
l'identification criminelle viennent de
terminer leur première constatation
découverte du corps et marquage des
indices au sol c'est au tour du médecin
légiste d'entrer en scène gants
combinaison sur bottes masques il doit
se protéger entièrement ne pas polluer
la scène de crime
premier conseil à Lolita
donc le but de tout ça c'est éviter
d'amener des indices et en particulier
votre ADN sur la scène de crime ce qui
veut dire qu'il faut pas que je vois vos
cheveux
[Musique]
mon deuxième cercle je
m'approche c'est le bosquet proprement
dit les traces
le chemin vous avez vu le sentier
d'être environnement je le regarde
est-ce qu'il y a une anomalie
particulière là le temps
[Applaudissements]
et puis mon troisième cercle c'est la
scène de crime telle qu'elle était
balisée donc par les gendarmes qui elle
effectivement fait la un carré de 10
mètres par 10
une scène de crimes balisée
indispensable pour repousser les curieux
il y a la fascination morbide tout
simple
parce qu'il y a pas le cadavre le
cadavre attire attire les gens
l'accident sur une bordure à bord de
route c'est une voiture est sur le toit
beaucoup de gens vont s'arrêter pour
regarder au loin pas forcément
s'impliquer mais ça va il y a une
fascination naturelle pour ça ce qui est
pas notre cas moi je fais ça plus pour
apporter des réponses surtout dans le
cadre des découvertes de cadavres on a
quand même des on a une victime
forcément mais on a des gens autour on a
de la famille et c'est important pour
eux de savoir ce qui s'est passé parce
qu'il faut que la vérité soit le dans le
cas d'un meurtre il faut que la vérité
soit mais il faut surtout aussi que les
personnes puissent faire leur deuil et
je pense qu'on a une responsabilité
importante à ce niveau là donc moi c'est
dur quand je sais pas quand je quand
j'ai pas trouvé ou là ça me pose des
problèmes après c'est c'est des
questions techniques donc
on fait abstraction des sentiments
personnels et puis on s'attarde sur ce
qui est technique quoi une paire de
lunettes avec un verbe droit absent
indice 5
[Applaudissements]
une chaussure
rien ne doit leur échapper chaussures
vêtements armes le moindre indice est
fondamental pour la suite de l'enquête
c'est un pistolet
semi-automatique sous le regard attentif
des gendarmes et de son étudiante Michel
sapinay prélève tout ce qu'il trouve et
le moindre indice est systématiquement
pris en photo pour l'instruction
sans les restes l'extrémité inférieure
d'un
[Applaudissements]
donc je pense que vraisemblablement la
main doit être quelque part là dedans
et ensuite donc la tête
donc c'est ça qu'ils ont ils ont vu en
premier lieu
donc là on a le crâne
on va voir dans quelle orientation il
est
vous comprenez Lolita en intervient sur
la scène une fois que les tics
techniciens d'investigation criminelles
sont passées ils ont tout repéré tout ce
qui est autour du corps
donc là ils ont eu des gentillesse de
nous attendre pour mettre les indices
dans les dans les sacs mais aussi bien
et j'aurais pu le faire l'avantage c'est
que on situe parfaitement la position de
chaque élément et l'arme en particulier
donc on a des lunettes assez loin une
chaussure une arme et encore
voilà donc après on verra
une fois qu'on aura dégagé tout ça
comment on peut intégrer un scénario
là-dedans
[Musique]
c'est intéressant d'avoir les hypothèses
des enquêteurs ça vous permet de prendre
le contre-pied éventuellement que ce
soit comme jeu ou comme technique parce
que si vous avez deux directions
d'enquête forcément on a une chance de
trouver une vérité et puis pour faire ça
c'est vrai que c'est beaucoup plus
informatif d'être sur les lieux que
d'être seulement dans sa salle de
toxique pour moi ça fait partie de
l'activité du médecin légiste et
effectivement c'est extrêmement
enrichissant
et agréable
la difficulté c'est de pas perdre dedans
donc il est vraisemblable qu'elles sont
tombées comme très souvent donc il me
faudra un sac papier
parce que tout ce qui est corporel donc
il contient de l'ADN il faut pouvoir
préserver cette ADN et de préférence on
met ça dans des sacs en papier kraft qui
permettent l'humidité de s'évacuer voilà
donc
ah oui effectivement
ça c'est des dents qui sont tombés après
la mort donc il faudra les récupérer
là-dedans
je vais le maxillaire supérieur qui est
parti en morceaux maintenant que les
indices sont répertoriés Michel sapanay
peut commencer à toucher au corps
la difficulté de prélever le squelette
en entier sans perdre le moindre
fragment d'os à chaque scène de crime
son environnement il faut savoir
s'adapter ici pas de coton-tige mais une
bêche alors la solution que j'ai adoptée
c'est la suivante
c'est de passer
suffisamment profond sous le corps
donc dégager bon évidemment là je pense
que je vais emporter quelques végétaux
mais c'est pas grave
mettez la planche pour rien
pas plus
on essaie de redresser la planche
voilà très bien
bon là on a de la chance
de sorte on allait les bas qui nous ont
tout gardé
voilà
tout ça on va l'emporter
le squelette placé sur une planche en
bois sera transférée au CHU pour faire
son autopsie donc ce qui serait
peut-être bien c'est que vous passiez un
petit coup de poêle à frire
[Musique]
on sait jamais avec les bijoux dernière
vérification avant de quitter les lieux
un travail minutieux rien n'est laissé
au hasard
c'est un vrai travail de fourmi en fait
[Musique]
faut trouver des auteurs quoi là où les
auteurs
et des heures des jours et des jours les
heures ça serait bien pour nous c'est
plutôt des jours
maintenant
il y a un gros travail de fait sur le
terrain mais il y a un énorme travail de
fait également en salle de toxique et
des fois on revient c'est pas parce
qu'on a prélevé le corps qu'on va
libérer le territoire on va faire garder
le territoire par les gendarmes tant
qu'on n'a pas trouvé des solutions
exactes de la mort naturelle ou du
meurtre mais on fait garder le la zone
24 heures sur 24 un gendarme est là pour
surveiller
les raisons de la mort
c'est la mission première du médecin
légiste
l'intervention du médecin légiste dans
l'enquête c'est dans les premières
heures
c'est ses propres constatations et c'est
aussi évidemment ce que lui demande le
juge d'instruction
et il y a une affaire que connaît bien
Dominique verdayan
une affaire dans laquelle les premières
constatations et l'autopsie ont été
bâclées il y a aujourd'hui une affaire
criminelle
qu'on cherche encore à résoudre
alors quelle date de 84
on espère trouver la solution dans l'ADN
c'est l'affaire Grégory
au commencement de l'enquête il y avait
deux médecins légistes dont le docteur
Pagel c'est elle qui a pratiqué
l'autopsie de Grégory il portait un
bonnet un anorak il avait une cordelette
autour du cou des mains et des chevilles
les liens n'étaient pas du tout serrés
le juge Lambert lui aussi était là il ne
voulait pas du tout qu'on fasse les
prélèvements accusent le docteur Pagel
ça nous a surpris on a insisté on a
juste obtenu l'autorisation de prélever
du sang et les poumons en émettant de
faire tous les prélèvements on a réduit
les possibilités de faire la lumière
enchaîne le professeur le Breton
l'autopsie du petit Grégory a été mal
faite alors elle a été mal faite
peut-être à cause du médecin légiste
mais aussi à cause du juge d'instruction
qui lui a donné une mission beaucoup
trop vague 25 ans après l'effet on ne
sait toujours pas si le petit Grégory
est mort noyé dans les eaux de la
Vologne ou si les morts avant et on ne
connaît toujours pas le coupable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il aura fallu plus de 2h à Michel
s'appelle pour expliquer à son étudiante
sa technique d'enquête sur le terrain
[Applaudissements]
les gendarmes de l'identification
criminelle libère les lieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le moment où le légiste peut
commencer son enquête médicale
[Musique]
enquêter pour comprendre
apprendre et répondre à des questions
physiques et philosophiques c'est ce qui
a donné naissance à la médecine légale
pourquoi ne la médecine légale sans
doute pour expliquer des choses
extraordinaires et peut-être
l'interrogation de l'homme par rapport à
des questions qui au départ dans
l'Antiquité en tout cas étaient
attribués au divin
et cette interrogation qui était déjà un
début de la science est-ce totalement
quelque chose de magique ce qui se passe
ou peut-on avoir une explication c'est
cette curiosité qui anime la médecine
légale
je fais la médecine légale donc je vois
du vivant je vois des morts
approchez la réalité et percer le
mystère qui entoure le corps et le crime
jusqu'à les autopsies ont connu au cours
de ces derniers siècles un développement
constant
on a appris à briser le tabou de la mort
et du corps la première autopsie
judiciaire on va dire en France en tout
cas que cet embrasse pareil directement
chirurgien du roi et ce roi François 1er
homme de la Renaissance homme de
curiosité
va en avant mais c'est aussi la période
où Vésale en Italie fait les premières
autopsies c'est la période où Leonard de
Vinci fait ce fameux schéma corporel
que l'on utilise toujours en médecine et
c'est la première description des corps
cette première interrogation une très
une autopsie très célèbre qui a lieu
c'est celle qui se fait après le tournoi
ou Henri II est blessé mortellement par
une lance qui lors d'un tournoi
occasionne des lésions crâniennes
encéphalique c'est une des premières
raisons et on a dans le judiciaire
énormément d'éléments c'est le début
c'est le début de l'arrivée de la preuve
dans le judiciaire alors que nous
n'oublions pas à l'époque il reposait
beaucoup sur la question c'est à dire la
torture les éléments d'aveu d'aveu a
toujours été très en avant on va vers
des preuves et non plus simplement la
vœu de culpabilité
l'univers des médecins légistes des
salles d'autopsie qui sentent la javel
une lumière lugubre
un métier à part qui fascine autant
qu'il effrait il doit pas y avoir de
limites au moyen utilisé parce qu'il
s'agit d'une personne c'est pour ça
qu'il faut que ça devienne un objet
d'étude le temps de l'autopsie c'est un
objet d'études une fois que le toxique
fini on le restaure on le lave on le
maquille on le rhabille et on le
réintègre en quelque sorte alors pas
dans la communauté des vivants parce que
là c'est un petit peu trop tard mais en
lui redonne sa qualité de personne mais
entre les deux il faut absolument que
j'en fasse un objet d'étude sinon enfin
une autopsie c'est extrêmement agressif
je rajoute au violence du de l'auteur
je rajoute alors c'est pas des violences
mais je rajoute mes propres mutilations
je l'ouvre complètement j'ouvre toutes
les cavités je prends tous les organes
c'est
la limite quand vous prenez un peu de
recul il y a des fois vous dites mais
c'est un boulot ignoble
c'est ignoble donc pour survivre à
l'ignoble il faut en faire un objet
sinon psychologiquement c'est pas
possible enfin ou alors c'est très
difficile ou alors on souffre j'ai pas
envie de souffrir à cause de mon métier
[Applaudissements]
l'unité médico-légale du CHU de Bordeaux
est l'une des plus importantes en France
plus de 500 autopsies y sont pratiqués
chaque année depuis 1996 Sophie gronde
dirige cette unité femme au parcours
atypique elle cumule les diplômes de
droit de science et de médecine
sophie grombe est une figure
emblématique de la médecine légale en
France pendant deux ans elle a travaillé
pour le Tribunal pénal international sur
les charniers au Kosovo pour identifier
les squelettes une expérience marquante
pour cette femme à leur jeune médecin
légiste Marilyn des chouwer forêt je
vous mets le coller et vous avez ces
coordonnées les affaires fourniraient
Pierrot le Fou Allègre le gendarme
Chabert c'était elle
Sophie Gron se prédestiné à une carrière
de commissaire de police mais c'est
assez naturellement qu'elle s'est
tournée vers la médecine légale pour
elle c'est avant tout un métier
d'enquêteur honnêtement je pense que
quand on fait médecine c'est pas a
priori pour aller découper son prochain
parce que bon c'est très prosaïque mais
c'est un peu la première image que ça
renvoie
c'est l'aboutissement d'un long
cheminement d'une double culture quand
même c'est à dire qu'en fait j'ai fait
médecine légale parce que j'étais
médecin et juriste et non l'inverse on
me dit souvent ah mais oui vous avez
fait du droit vous êtes médecin légiste
c'est normal en fait non non pas du tout
c'est parce que j'étais médecin et
juriste que j'ai fait de la médecine
légale mais c'est passionnant je
regrette pas
[Musique]
je vais attendu ma chérie comment
aujourd'hui Sophie grombe a réuni une
vingtaine de médecins légistes de la
région Aquitaine il travaille souvent
seul sans les moyens techniques du CHU
il faut donc les remettre à niveau
l'objectif est de mettre au point un
protocole pour harmoniser les méthodes
de prélèvement pendant une autopsie
c'est une phase clé la moindre erreur
peut avoir des conséquences judiciaires
graves la veille un motard a été amenée
à l'unité médico-légale décédée sur la
voie publique sans témoin son autopsie
est obligatoire pour l'identification du
corps et pour déterminer s'il n'a pas
fait un malaise préalable à son accident
étape numéro 1
le corps doit être entièrement scanner
sous le contrôle de Sophie gronde c'est
une autre légiste du CHU de Bordeaux qui
dirige l'autopsie
de la canicule gauche
pour la main aussi
elle facture
une remise à niveau pour certains pour
d'autres l'occasion d'échanger des
conseils
parce que vous vous mettez pas de devant
un petit coucou
[Musique]
1 m
802 l'examen du corps
les nages beige à rayures encolure en
vêtement lésion externe ecchymose
coupure le moindre détail est mentionné
dans un rapport d'autopsie
également par les secours c'est pas du
cuir en fait
façon cuire alors
comment tu sais que c'est pas du cul
parce que
oui
les choses sérieuses commencent
changement de temps
c'est le moment où il faut faire parler
le corps
pour déterminer s'il s'agit d'une
hémorragie d'un accident n'est pas
d'ivresse ou d'un arrêt cardiaque
il faut passer en revue une à une toutes
les hypothèses
tout le monde a l'air décontracté en
apparence c'est vrai que dans le métier
de médecin légiste enfin à la dose où
nous l'exerçant à Bordeaux c'est à dire
du temps plein ou nous ne faisons que de
la violence effectivement il faut être
assez équilibré et avoir autre chose et
des dérivatives je crois que c'est
important sinon on peut pas on tient pas
c'est très dur on voit en permanence je
dis souvent c'est affreux ça allait
méchants en permanence
une fois lavé l'examen interne commence
le corps est entièrement ouvert
un nain tous les organes vont être
prélevés pesées disséquer et répertorié
moment clé de la formation c'est souvent
à ce moment-là que les erreurs
interviennent
c'est à aller chercher
ilhac du sang périphérique c'est la
première chose avant de faire quoi que
ce soit avant de percer l'estomac avant
de faire quoi que ce soit et le dosage
quantitatif se fait sur ça
elle fait le screening sur le reste et
le quantitatif et tout la toxico qui est
faite au-dessus du diaphragme mais
fausse je peux vous dire que les
contre-expertise sont légion et moi la
bile c'est 17
17 ml de pile environ 1000 contre
expertises médicales seraient pratiquées
chaque année
149 la machine judiciaire doit alors se
remettre en route c'est souvent
fastidieux et refaire une autopsie peut
s'avérer compliqué
un petit peu quand même
éventuellement
on le pèse
puis on le filtre regarde ça je vais
regarder si tu as des confinement c'est
pas du tout
c'est pas c'est des éléments Blanchards
je vais les prendre et puis on va mettre
en toxico tu vois ça peut être du pomme
de terre
européenne
on propose une technique ça c'est la
mienne
mais bon n'oubliez pas quand même que
quand vous avez le moindre doute sur du
lancer ou du post mortem il faut laver
on lave pas assez il faut laver laver
laver laver ça ne craint rien vous
pouvez mettre tout sous l'eau et si ça
se dit tout enfin l'anté mortelle se
disent tout donc on avance
allez on y va
l'autopsie a duré plus d'une heure une
heure d'analyse de prélèvement une heure
pour connaître l'origine du décès en
fait un banal accident ce moteur est
mort sur le coup
le corps a été meurtri disséqué découpé
un spectacle pénible pour le commun des
mortels
est-ce que vous avez déjà garantie de
vous retrouver justement à la place de
ces personnes là non j'ai jamais pensé
j'ai jamais pensé mais
bon mon somme de range pas parce que je
trouve que c'est important pour ceux qui
restent de savoir de quoi est décédé une
personne c'est il y a un gros sentiment
de culpabilité chez les personnes qui
entourent un défunt je le sais parce que
je reçois beaucoup de familles et je
vois bien que les familles sont
visiblement heureuses entre guillemets
bien sûr de rencontrer la dernière
personne qui a touché à l'être cher et
qui est capable de leur dire de quoi il
est mort comment ont été les dernières
heures de la vie je pense que c'est très
important bon le monde il faut que le
mort on n'est plus là pour savoir mais
pour ceux qui restent je crois que c'est
important on arrive à faire abstraction
de de cette vision du corps et surtout
de se dire qu'est-ce qu'elle qu'est-ce
que la personne a ressenti parce que
c'est ça en fait qui qui est un petit
peu troublant parce que c'est un acte
technique et que on cherche la
manifestation de la vérité on cherche
les causes de la mort on cherche un
trajet de balle voilà donc on est
méticuleux dans notre pas assez
technique et on voit pas la personne en
fait
aider les familles à faire leur deuil
déterminer les causes de la mort aider à
trouver des coupables c'est la partie de
la médecine légale la plus connue mais
dans certains cas les gîtes travaillent
aussi avec les vivants Sophie grombe a
créé le Covin 1999 le premier centre
d'accueil en urgence des victimes
d'agression
simple bagarre violence conjugale viol
agression sur mineur afin d'éviter la
lourdeur des procédures toutes ces
personnes blessées physiquement et
psychologiquement sont reçus par des
assistantes sociales des psychologues
des juristes et des médecins légistes
[Musique]
87 ce matin je nommé là après s'être
fait agresser en sortant de boîte de
nuit la médecin légiste le reçoit pour
un examen poussé et faire ses premières
constatations
la victime doit raconter dans les
moindres détails ce qu'il s'est passé
pendant l'agression
parce que c'est les gens que vous
connaissez ou pas
du tram et donc ce qui s'est passé c'est
que va agresser
[Applaudissements]
à l'issue de l'entretien ce jeune homme
aura entre les mains une interruption
temporaire de travail pour son employeur
une pièce fondamentale qui l'aidera en
cas de poursuite judiciaire
l'idée qui va pousser à créer le Cova et
que la médecine légale est une médecine
d'expertise auxiliaire de justice on
pèse on mesure on écrit des rapports au
kilomètre c'est un peu déshumanisé et
nous avions face à nous nous l'avons
toujours une population
en souffrance parfois même désespérée et
je trouvais qu'on pouvait être beaucoup
plus utile et soignant aussi parce que
pour être médecin légiste on en est pas
moins médecin tous les lundis l'équipe
se réunit pour faire le point sur les
dossiers de la semaine passée
elle elle est étonnante dans son
comportement parce qu'elle n'hésite pas
à redonner au père alors que souvent
quand on pense qu'il y a un danger on
les redonne pas souvent des dossiers
très complexes comme les cas d'agression
sur mineur quand est-ce qu'elle doit
donner les réunions nécessaires pour
échanger les points de vue et mettre en
place un suivi social et psychologique
pourquoi ça a été barré parce qu'il est
pas venu TB c'est pas vrai
Sonia en fait donc c'est une jeune fille
qui
qui a pu se saisir d'une d'un séjour en
colonie vacances pour pour révéler une
animatrice de la colonie qu'elle était
donc maltraitée physiquement dans un
premier temps par ses parents donc suite
à cette suite assez révélations il y a
une mesure avec un suivi éducatif qui a
été mis en place et donc fin début
janvier elle a pu par rapport au lien
qu'elle avait écrit avec l'éducatrice se
révéler les les viols qu'elle
subissaient depuis l'âge de 8 non 4 ans
ça commence à l'âge de 4 ans voilà donc
elle a pu en parler à l'éducatrice donc
elle a été il y a eu un placement au
foyer dans un foyer donc voilà donc elle
parle de voilà de elle parle de viol de
son frère et de ses frères voilà et de
son oncle du côté matériel
entre 21 et 24 et
sanguins la deuxième langue permettre
les révélations c'est que elle est très
inquiète pour sa petite sœur de 8 ans
donc
dans la famille
mais on la protège pas plus
des dossiers compliqués comme celui-là
ils entrent 4000 par an
la grande vient de faire
retour à Poitiers
dans les sous-sols du CHU le service de
la médecine légale le service de Michel
sapanay
pour demain matin
[Musique]
là il est 20h un corps vient d'arriver
comme tous les cadavres qui doivent être
autopsiés il doit passer au scanner
problème la machine est au deuxième
étage le service de médecine légale au
sous-sol alors il faut être le plus
discret possible
une petite partie de cache-cache
commence dans les couloirs de l'hôpital
il ne faut pas être vu les vivants d'un
côté les morts de l'autre chacun à sa
place
vous vous cachez là oui pourquoi par
rapport au vivant
[Musique]
c'est mal vécu au sein de l'hôpital
parce que les médecins ont un rapport à
la mort qui est particulier différent
des autres médecins il est certain que
il y a un rapport particulier avec la
vie et avec la mort les deux
le définir c'est très difficile ce que
je sais c'est que
[Musique]
ça permet de s'accoutumer à l'idée de sa
propre mort
ça permet de prendre conscience de la
valeur de la vie au cas où on l'aurait
oublié et ça relativise considérablement
tous les événements qui n'ont pas de
gravité réelle
[Musique]
autour de la chambre froide
une odeur un peu particulière
un définissable pour certains
[Musique]
mais reconnaissable pour d'autres
semaines
le putréfié à une odeur qui varie avec
les étapes ça peut être beurre rance
après c'est un petit peu stylé ouest et
puis après ça s'aggrave très nettement
comme ici vous avez encore à supporter
oui c'est l'habitude
on met pas les petits produits enfin moi
je mets pas les petits produits j'aime
bien garder mon odorat et pouvoir m'en
servir si besoin
basse je fumais des cigares aussi dans
ces cas-là maintenant j'ai plus besoin
allez on ferme
[Musique]
le lendemain matin Michel sapinay
continue la formation de Lolita
l'étudiante en médecine ils vont
autopsier le squelette retrouver dans
les bois pendant la reconstitution de
scènes de crime
le but aujourd'hui c'est d'apprendre à
Lolita à retrouver l'identité d'un
squelette
[Musique]
voilà donc le but
trouver
les éléments qui peuvent intéresser les
enquêteurs dans cet ensemble qui nous
vient des bois est-ce que c'est plus
compliqué de trouver l'origine d'un
décès sur un squelette ou sur un cadavre
récent frais
ça va dépendre si on a un enfoncement de
la boîte crânienne on peut
imaginer un traumatisme crânien mais
s'il y a pas une trace sur le
on n'aura pas la cause on peut avoir une
plaie par coup de couteau une plaie par
balle sans qui aucune trace sur les
autres par exemple une femme qui serait
étranglée
le larynx au bout de trois ou quatre ans
il y en a plus c'est une structure
plutôt cartilagineuse donc la
strangulation disparaîtra les traces de
la strangulation disparaîtront
tout ceci on va gentiment il est
possible de faire parler un squelette et
trouver un maximum d'indices pour
élaborer un scénario criminel et
déterminer un âge et un sexe j'ai plus
rien des mains et des pieds
les ossements sont bien conservés mais
éparpillés
première difficulté
reconstituer le squelette
cela peut prendre plusieurs heures
dans cet état il faut combien de temps
il faut plusieurs années
je suis sur
je pense au moins trois ans
toute la terre retrouvée sur les lieux
du crime doit être tamisée pour
retrouver le moindre fragment qui s'est
détaché
[Musique]
tout ça alors explique une connexion ça
c'est quoi ça c'est un caillou
donc on va refaire le tri après il y a
du travail
puisqu'il va falloir
étudier chaque osse remettre chaque os à
sa place on a fait un squelette complet
là aussi je suis sur une chemise de nuit
à large échancrure
je peux avoir une balle dans le corps
sans avoir
une chemise de nuit de vieilles dames un
premier indice ne rien oublier ne rien
laisser au hasard c'est toute la
difficulté de ce travail
au service de la justice c'est assez
enquêteur de l'ombre d'apporter le
maximum de réponses ça peut être utile
de le donner aux enquêteurs
une demi-journée ou une journée entière
quand vous êtes au procès que
donc vous arrivez aux assises que vous
faites votre déposition d'experts que
vous éclairez tout ce qui a été dit
avant en particulier la façon dont
l'accusé relatait les fêtes quand vous
montrez que ce qu'il dit
tout à fait inexact quand vous prouvez
ces contradictions par rapport à ce que
vous dites le corps on a un rôle
effectivement qui est majeur donc c'est
pour ça qu'il faut faire aussi attention
à ce qu'on dit
[Musique]
voilà ça c'est ce qu'il y avait près de
la tête
voilà très bien c'est quoi ça
c'est important pour éliminer une
strangulation voilà Aurélie minet une
strangulation exactement
donc là j'ai un demi maxillaire
maxillaire gauche et là j'ai l'autre
demi maxillaire m'accélère droit
les deux ensemble ça c'est intéressant
parce que cette personne
a une couronne
un soin de terre ici
bon on fera des radios pour voir s'il y
a des soins qu'on ne verrait pas
ceci par exemple ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle une résine donc ce sont des
techniques
classique donc ça veut dire qu'elle a un
dossier dentaire là il manque dedans
mais ça c'est des chutes post mortem
donc je vous ai dit parce que les
alvéoles sont parfaitement visibles
c'est pas une extraction en tortème
puisque à ce moment-là on a un caillot
on a des du tissu de fibrose à
l'intérieur qui va boucher levéole dans
quelques semaines ce qui va falloir
reconstruire refaire c'est ça
là on récupère une hauteur de visage
c'est à partir de ça on peut
effectivement
faire des évaluations
de portrait
grâce à plusieurs indices les habits les
tue des ossements et la dentition Michel
sapanay pourrait facilement retrouver
l'identité de la victime
[Musique]
dans certains crimes mystérieux le
médecin légiste et le seul à pouvoir
donner une identité à un corps
1991 l'affaire Simone Weber des frais la
chronique cette fameuse soupçonnée
d'avoir fait disparaître son amant
Bernard etiet dont on est sans nouvelles
mais pas de corps donc pas de crime
jusqu'à ce que quelques mois plus tard
un pêcheur tombe sur une valise avec à
l'intérieur un tronc très difficile à
identifier
il y a vraiment plus que le corps il y a
plus la tête il y a plus les bras le
corps est un peu en état déjà
décomposition avancées donc le corps est
confié à un médecin légiste et on
compare évidemment
ce qu'il constate sur le tronc
et ce qu'on peut avoir du dossier
médical
de Bernard et calque et radio à l'appui
le professeur coudan établit son
diagnostic il existe une concordance
très grande entre les radios de Bernard
laitier et celle du tronc repêché dans
la valise et donc on est dans un espèce
de mécano qu'on va totalement d'ailleurs
reconstruire à l'audience madame Weber
dira oui oui on essaye de de
s'approprier ce Tron ah oui parce que ce
trou effectivement le médecin légiste
dit c'est celui de Bernard routier et
donc c'est évidemment l'argument qui à
la fois évidemment pendant l'instruction
va être un élément à charge contre
Simone Weber et c'est un des éléments
qui va être à charge pour sa
condamnation être condamné à 20 ans de
réclusion criminelle
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui dans une cour
d'assise ce que dit le médecin légiste
est considéré comme
s'en bavure sans discussion ce qui me
plaît le plus c'est redonner de
l'humanité assez victimes et
effectivement
participé à la sanction du coupable
lorsqu'il y en a ou participé au
contraire au fait qu'il soit innocent
[Musique]
mais quand l'identification est
impossible en dernier recours ont fait
appel en France aux gendarmes de l'IRCGN
à Rosny-sous-Bois en région parisienne
l'institut de recherche criminelle de la
gendarmerie nationale c'est ici que des
ossements sont envoyés de toute la
France pour expertise au département
anthropologique thanatologie sa mission
identifier les corps et rechercher les
causes et circonstances des décès
le médecin chef Yves chouliard fait
partie de l'équipe d'expert il est
médecin légiste son laboratoire unique
en France ses spécialisé dans la
reconstruction faciale à partir des
crânes
pour la reconstruction faciale
c'est une méthode qu'on utilise en
dernier recours dans toutes les autres
techniques d'identification
l'aboutissent pas et quand notamment on
n'a pas d'éléments comparatifs on n'a
pas de piste on va tenter par la
reconstitution faciale d'approcher le
visage réel de la personne de manière à
ce que ce visage soit diffusé par les
enquêteurs ou par les médias et que
quelqu'un dise oui ça me rappelle une
personne que je connais et donc ça va
relancer l'enquête on a on a des retours
positifs tout à fait alors je sais pas
si j'ai pas des exemples à vous montrer
que je retrouve le dossier
sourire
voilà donc
voilà le la numérisation du crâne avec
la ici il y a quelques standards
d'épaisseur qui ont été positionnés un
visage de synthèse qui a été établi en
fonction déjà des données
anthropométriques et ce visage de
synthèse est déformé vous pouvez venir
se plaquer sur le crâne avec les
standards d'épaisseur et voilà ici
le résultat obtenu ensuite lorsque le
résultat est obtenu on peut faire un
habillage avec des cheveux etc parce
qu'on a un logiciel de portrait-robot
qui nous permet donc d'affiner les
résultats alors voilà quelques exemples
de réussite de par cette méthode donc la
diffusion
de ces portraits dans le système a
permis donc de retrouver ces personnes
on n'a pas l'impression de refaire
parfaitement le visage de une personne
mais il y a quand même des éléments qui
permettent donc à quelqu'un qui connaît
cette personne de
d'être interpellé de dire oui ça me
rappelle quelqu'un que je connais ça
peut être voilà après on vérifie par
d'autres techniques un résultat proche
de la réalité
une méthode qui a révolutionné le
travail des médecins légistes pour les
enquêtes les plus compliquées comme dans
les catastrophes naturelles les
tremblements de terre le tsunami de 2002
où les accidents d'avion comme au
Venezuela ou 152 Martiniquais ont été
tués
quelle est l'affaire qui a été le plus
compliqué pour vous psychologiquement il
y en a deux il y a l'affaire du tunnel
du Mont-Blanc qui a été très compliqué à
mettre en oeuvre parce que c'est
vraiment des conditions on était en
plein milieu du tunnel à 6 km de la
sortie donc fallait travailler dans le
noir dans les conditions difficiles ça
fait très long il fallait identifier des
véhicules dans le tunnel pour avoir une
idée de qui pouvait se trouver dans ces
véhicules et donc à la spécialiste du
département véhicule qui sont allés avec
nous pour d'abord identifier les
véhicules carbonisés sur les 40
personnes décédées 5 ont été
formellement identifiés
les hommes de la police scientifique et
les médecins légistes éprouvent les
pires difficultés à mettre un nom sur
les corps
imaginez ce qui peut rester
quand la température a dépassé plusieurs
centaines de degrés pendant 24 heures ou
48 heures il a fallu 15 jours de
constatation à l'intérieur du tunnel
pouvoir retrouver et sortir les corps du
tunnel ensuite il a fallu 15 autres
jours d'examen des corps pour arriver
aux identifications et l'autre à faire
qui a été compliqué c'est une des
dernières affaires du Venezuela donc un
crash d'avion près de Maracaibo où là
les corps étaient extrêmement abîmés
avec des relevés dans des conditions
très difficiles et il a fallu faire de
l'ADN sur tous les corps pour arriver à
les identifier ça a été très long très
difficile donc c'est les deux affaires
les plus
qui ont été pour nous techniquement les
plus les plus durs
ça permet de rendre aux familles les
corps qui leur appartiennent avec
certitude
et puis quand les personnes retrouvent
le corps qui appartiennent donc elles
peuvent entraver leur travail de deuil
je crois que c'est attendre elle est
abominable et nous on est actuellement
on essaie de la réduire
[Musique]
les légistes ces experts qui trouvent
des solutions à tout ou presque sont
maintenant les stars du petit écran
leur univers fascine et les producteurs
l'ont bien compris
les séries les experts Bones et ris
cartonne
[Musique]
benjamin dupontubiens est un des
producteurs de RIS Police Scientifique
une série qui suit les investigations
d'une équipe d'enquêteurs
une fois par semaine il réunit les
auteurs pour peaufiner des scénarios
parfois inspirés d'histoire vrai donc 14
juillet
[Musique]
tu as forcément un char d'assaut expose
une bagnole dans le civil tu as une
armée de militaires qui verrouille le
truc alors que tu fais venir tu fais
rêver les flics quelque part avant les
militaires en militaires ils sont sur
place tu vois ils sont en colonne de
char les uns les autres tu as un char
qui s'échappe qui fasse une bagnole les
autres ils mettent à trois heures
arriver quoi ils arrêtent les chats il
est son il bloque la scène la scène de
crime est à nous stop la police
militaire arrive il y a des officiers
qui débarquent sur le champ ils sont à 2
mètres de là sur les Champs-Élysées ils
vont débarqué dans la minute et quand
les flics débarquent les flics
débarquent après ok on a des on a le
crime on a des gens qui ont des mobiles
pour faire ça on a des gens qui s'aiment
qui séparent et tout mais sur le fond
des choses moi j'y crois pas l'histoire
encore l'objectif est d'être le plus
réaliste possible avec comme seul
contrainte faire en 50 minutes ce que
les techniciens font en plusieurs
semaines je crois que c'est cyrilac soit
les experts ou risques et finalement une
une déclinaison à la française de cette
thématique là de trouver les de résoudre
des crimes par la preuve et de
d'approcher la mort de manière un peu
scientifique c'est quelque chose de
rassurant ce qui rassure vachement les
gens moi je pense c'est de se dire ah
c'est super de se dire qu'aujourd'hui la
science peut tout résoudre la science
peut soigner les gens donc on est la
preuve typique et la science peut
trouver des coupables quel que soit les
mecs que je mets à la tête du risque ou
qui vont inquiéter la science va trouver
le coupable pour les aider les auteurs
ont un référent médecins légistes et
entomologistes le professeur Gosset à
Lille
sur la série avec nous donc on l'utilise
en consultant en amont pour trouver des
sujets on aime bien aller déjeuner avec
lui ou l'inviter sur le plateau pour
discuter avec lui puis il nous raconte
sa vie et puis il suffit d'appuyer sur
le bouton Play et puis on les coupe
parler pendant des heures et puis on
ressort avec plein d'idées c'est un vrai
bonheur et puis sinon quand on a après
nous écrit des textes et qu'on a des
scènes d'autopsie on lui soumet les on
lui soumet les scènes pour voir avec lui
le contenu voir sur un compte pas trop
de conneries mais pour dépeindre la
réalité il a fallu dépasser la fiction
et assister à des autopsies
cette fois-ci pour de vrai moi je vous
avoue que non
j'ai toujours refusé je suis très
sensible je tourne de très rapidement
devant les choses très très réelles
comme ça et puis dans les dans les
auteurs je travaille sur la série les
trois quarts l'ont fait ce voyage pas
tous et au niveau des comédiens c'est
vrai que nos deux comédiens principaux
ont assisté à des autopsies pour les
deux qui font les légistes ou inciter
les autopsies ils ont pas tenu entier
ils ont pas tenu la durée de l'autopsie
complète ils ont assisté au début et
après ils ont vu merci je pense que
c'est plutôt l'enquête criminelle qui
interpelle dans ces dans ces séries là
les questions qu'on me pose par contre
ou lorsqu'on me dit je voudrais faire
médecine légale voilà je suis je suis en
troisième je voudrais faire médecine
légal bon je commence par leur dire bon
bah d'accord mais il faut d'abord être
médecin
ah bon je suis en Première je voudrais
faire médecine légale oui d'accord faut
d'abord être médecin puis le médecin
légiste il faut d'abord être un médecin
du vivant et après vous pouvez passer au
médecin de la mort quand j'ai de demande
de voir des autopsies aussi parce que ça
ça arrive très souvent
voir des autopsies là c'est un autre
phénomène parce que les gens savent que
ce n'est pas la technique scientifique
qui vont voir c'est vraiment le boulot
du légiste et là je crois que souvent ça
répond à des problématiques personnelles
je veux voir une autopsie parce que j'ai
besoin de comprendre quelque chose de la
mort que je peux pas trouver autrement
qu'avec un légiste
voilà qu'est-ce que je deviens après la
mort comment est mon corps après la mort
où se trouve mon âme
misère sociale agression accident crime
la médecine légale est là pour éclairer
les moments obscurs
une pratique qui brise les tabous de la
mort pour raconter une histoire
l'histoire des derniers instants d'une
vie
[Musique]